[Música]
[Aplausos]
un italiano un siciliano en bilbao os
preguntaréis por qué no bueno ya sabéis
los bilbaínos nacemos donde nos dé la
gana así que es muy sencillo pero no
vengo aquí hoy para hablaros de para
presumir de mí ni de mi bilbaína edad ni
de miseria ni edad vengo aquí para
presumir de humanismo es decir para
hablaros de humanismo y para deciros que
una economía una economía distinta pero
que no sea una economía antisistema
existe y se ha teorizado lo que pasa que
en el siglo 18 cuando se teoriza la
economía civil que es lo de que os vengo
a hablar hoy no llegó a ser la economía
mainstream es decir el canal principal
sabéis esto pasa con las tecnologías
estamos hablando de tecnologías buena
etapa seguramente los más jóvenes menos
pero los que tenéis algún año y tomás os
acordaréis que un debate en los años 80
entre sí el sistema hs o el beta se iban
a firmar para las cintas no bueno pasó
que el beta se casco mi padre compró una
cámara no supo qué hacer
me regaló a mí y lo que pasó fue que el
hs se confirmó como primer tecnología
qué pasó ahí no sabemos pero hubo que
una tecnología se afirmó por encima de
otra eso la economía política que es la
que a mí me toca todos los días en la
universidad de deusto enseñar a mis
alumnos es la teoría que nosotros
utilizamos como economistas sean
economía política fijaros y os vengo
hablar de economía civil ya las palabras
cambian no poli polis política y civil
ya la polis es una cosa la shyris yo
tuvo que estudiar muchos años latino y
la verdad que esto quizás se me ha
quedado en la cabeza un poco pero la
póliza la civil son dos cosas distintas
y os explico por qué porque la palabra
clave de la economía civil es
inclusividad de simplicidad pero sobre
todo es relacionalidad cuando los
romanos conquistaban una tierra lo que
hacían eran dejar la cultura de la
tierra o del país o de la ciudad que
conquistaban y añadirles a lo que ya
tenían la ciudadanía romana es decir era
un sistema inclusivo es decir tú eres el
que eres pero también a partir de ahora
es romano y está el modelo de philips
inclusivo
en cambio la polis seguramente os
acordaréis de esparta de atenas de estas
grandes ciudades eran exclusivas se
cerraban y todo de hecho eran ciudades
estados estaban cerradas ahí entonces os
venga hablar de la economía de la
economía civil y cuando os digo de la
economía civil quiero decir una cosa
en el paradigma que nosotros presentamos
que utilizamos hay unos textos que
utilizan los mismos modelos pero con
variables distintas y fundamentalmente
dice que para que funcione una economía
tiene que haber tres grandes criterios
tres grandes cosas cuáles son estas tres
grandes cosas 1 eficiencia 2 equidad y 3
fraternidad que puede sonar un poco así
pero os cuento rápido solo si estas tres
variables solo si estas tres
características están dentro de nuestros
modelos solo si hay las tres
simultáneamente nuestros modelos
económicos funcionan porque fijaros un
momento hemos tenido experiencia de
sistemas que tienen eficiencia y estamos
en ello pero no tienen equidad y no
tienen fraternidad pues probablemente
las desigualdades que vivimos en nuestro
mundo se deben a esto es decir hay una
serie de problemáticas pero también
hemos tenido modelos donde sí se
premiaba la equidad pero no se estaba
privando lo que es la eficiencia y la
fraternidad a que voy al socialismo real
que hemos visto que también ha fracasado
y tercero diréis hombre fraternidad es
mucho mejor da igual
podría ser ya que estamos en una santa
casa hablar del reino de los cielos
cuidado la fraternidad si no está
acompañada de la equidad y si no está
acompañada por la eficiencia tiene el
riesgo de transformarse en grupos de
poder el lobby bueno vengo de sicilia en
mafias podríamos decir de alguna forma
son magias entonces la economía civil
tiene en su historia en su creación
básicamente esta idea de que las tres
componentes equidad eficiencia y
fraternidad funcionen pero hay otro
elemento quiere superar tres grandes
reduccionismos que son los tres grandes
reduccionismos que tenemos en nuestros
modelos de economía política cuáles son
el reduccionismo del concepto de empresa
la empresa hasta ahora por lo menos yo
cuando estudiaba en italia he aprendido
que lo que hay que hacer es maximizar
beneficios entonces martínez dando
beneficios los únicos beneficiarios de
esto son los accionistas da igual ya que
el trabajador se despida o que el
proveedor se machaque lo importante es
que el accionista a final de año final
de mes a final de trimestre tenga su
dividendo pues no hay que superar esta
visión y de hecho
si os fijáis en la economía siempre más
esto se habla de empresas
multistakeholder es decir hay que tener
en cuenta todos los diferentes actores
que están dentro de la economía de una
empresa hay superar primero este hay que
superar este reduccionismo segundo
reduccionismo que hay que superar el
reduccionismo del valor nos han
machacado de que el pp del pd muy bien
el cb es una variable muy cierta pero
mide el crecimiento tenemos que tener en
cuenta en nuestros modelos el desarrollo
siempre le digo a mis alumnos cómo
entender la diferencia entre crecimiento
desarrollo mira tu compañero mide 190 y
otro mide 160 a saber quién es más listo
de los dos el hecho de ser más alto no
significa que eres más listo no entonces
el desarrollo que es algo cualitativo
probablemente nuestros modelos nos
saltamos y no lo involucramos y por
último el más importante
el reduccionismo antropológicos de
nuestros modelos de economía política
pensar un momento que significa plantear
en un aula universitaria que las
decisiones que asumimos en nuestros
modelos se fundamentan en un ser humano
que es el homo economicus que es el
modelo de ser humano el prototipo que
utilizamos en nuestros modelos es un ser
humano así le contamos maximizador de
utilidad es decir si tienes tres globos
y tienes cinco globos cuántos cuál de
las dos opciones eliges la donde hay más
porque va siembra más amas más robert
frank que es un economista muy famoso en
eeuu en su libro de microeconomía dice
yo nunca dejaría salir mi hija con el
homo economicus que planteó el mismo de
los económicos porque es un monstruo es
un bestia es un tío que no tiene ningún
tipo de criterio más allá de la
maximización de la utilidad entonces
todo esto puede sonar como quizás un
poco raro un poco bueno un poco así y os
quiero plantear una pequeña historia es
un juego acercándome a trabajar con los
que han sido históricamente los
profesores de los que yo estudiaba pero
que se han transformado con el paso en
el tiempo
en mis coautores de cierre podido he
tenido la suerte escribir con ellos me
he podido acercar a lo que es el modelo
de la economía comportamental
entonces lo que he hecho ha sido
descubrir que existen formas de poder
investigar sobre las personas y hacer
juegos para ver cómo reaccionan las
personas no a raíz de todo lo que os he
dicho hay un juego que se llama el
dilema del dictador que hace se coge en
la gente dentro de una sala con dinero
de verdad se dividen en parejas y a las
parejas se le otorga a cada pareja una
cantidad de cien euros y se le dice uno
de los dos tendrá que ser el dictador es
decir la persona que decide cómo
repartir el dinero y el segundo que es
el respondedor pues tendrá que decidir
si aceptar y entonces se divide como el
dictador ha dicho o rechazar la
propuesta nadie se queda con el dinero
se entiende no la espera es muy sencilla
uno elige y el otro dice sí o no
y os pregunto si os toca a vosotros los
que estáis presente aquí como os
repartiría es el dinero
es un test muy rápido
imaginaros que se hoy sois el dictador
que le propondría es a vuestro a vuestra
pareja
mitad 50-50
50 50 50 50
hay un 80 20 bien eso parece una subasta
no
sí
bien pero mayoritariamente por lo que se
escucha tampoco tenemos el tiempo
restringido parece que la mayoría de
vosotros ha dicho 50/50 bueno alguno se
ha lanzado un poco más pero fijaros
habéis dicho y habéis planteado un
reparto que es
cuidado si utilizáramos el modelo de
economía que yo planteo y knaul a mis
alumnos cuál hubiera sido vuestra
respuesta qué es la respuesta racional y
la más macs iniciadora de utilidad yo
soy el dictador
me quedo con 99 tú eres el respondedor
te quedas con uno porque porque uno para
ti es mejor que decirme que no hay que
darte con cero
pero esto es un monstruo un tío que
piensa así pues esto es el lomo
económicos ese es el modelo que
utilizamos en nuestras análisis
económicas entonces la economía civil lo
que procura es romper este modelo y
romper no es fácil
pues quiero despedirme quiero despedir
de vosotros con una pequeña historia
esperanzadora bien es una historia que
viene del mundo árabe cuenta de que un
padre que tenía tres hijos al morir dejó
11 camellos en herencia
sabéis que cuando herencias hay mal
rollo hay temas gentes que se empiezan a
dar si hay cosas muy malas no zancos
ante as bien el padre además no se le
deberían dar muy bien los números no era
un ingeniero ni aerospacial ni nada no
no no se le daban muy bien los números
entonces el problema que tuvo este señor
dijo al primer hijo el mayor le voy a
dejar la mitad de mi herencia al segundo
le voy a dejar una cuarta parte y al
tercero una sexta parte os ayudo yo once
entre dos es cinco y medio y hasta ahí
es sencillo 11 entre 4 es 2 con 75 y 11
entre 6 que es la parte del tercero es 1
con 85 86 algo así vale como veis la
fracción de que las cosas no funcionan
después de morir el padre dejó como el
legado a los hermanos bien
empezaron a pelearse no hubo forma de
solucionarlo no hubo forma de arreglar
esto todos empiezan así que hacemos
bueno vendemos los cambios esto no pero
nuestro padre nos ha dicho que vende los
caminos no si no lo hubiera hecho él no
para qué no si lo que queríamos hacer
era nuestro padre nos quería dejar los
camellos no podemos matar un camello no
sé qué hacer el camel schering no de
esto de que reparte es que venga no no
se puede entonces tenemos que buscar una
solución bueno hasta que llega por
aquella aldea donde los pobres hermanos
estaban ahí peleándose y no encontrando
una solución un señor
un viajero con su propio camello este
señor dijo mira os voy a ayudar yo es
muy sencillo os voy a regalar mi camello
esto ya qué majo qué majo muy bien nada
todo muy bien de ahí pobre pero el pobre
no para arreglar un cuento dice bueno y
vosotros mismos vale ahora tenéis 12
camellos vais a repartir los no sí sí sí
claro claro entonces un medio el primero
el mayor se quedaba con 6 que es la
mitad de 12 el segundo se quedó con 3
que es una cuarta parte de 12 y el
último el más pequeño no se quedaba con
dos camellos que era una sexta parte de
12 pues estáis de acuerdo si sus hitos
de acuerdo vale bueno al repartir los
camellos se dieron cuenta que seis más
tres más dos era 11 y le sobraba un
camello claro que el camello de que el
hombre se quedó y se llevó hijo bueno
hasta luego yo me voy
quizás el padre la herencia mejor que
hubiera tenido que dejar a estas
personas que él estaba dejando era de
que frente a un problema siempre que hay
un problema es mucho más fácil es mucho
más sencillo estar en una actitud
cooperativa es decir la cooperación es
siempre y no la maximización de la
utilidad propia es la mejor alternativa
incluso cuando en nuestros modelos suena
y parece irracional y con este mensaje
esperanzador os quiero dejar muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]